Bonjour,
je m'appelle Fabien Olicard.
Dans ce format nous faisons un focus
sur un point particulier du cerveau.
Dans les épisodes précédents vous nous
avez proposé d'aborder les biais cognitifs.
C'est le sujet du jour,
bienvenue dans matière grise.
[Musique]
Dans cet épisode, nous allons
vivre quatre expériences.
Expérience 1, tous biaisés.
Expérience 2, lecture de pensées.
Expérience 3, le grand test collectif.
Expérience 4, c'est à vous.
Le tout, avec la présence
très appréciée de Simon Astier.
Il est presque certain que vous avez
déjà tous entendu parler des biais cognitif.
Quelque chose de biaisé,
c'est quelque chose qui va pas droit
d'un côté, qui est biaisé.
Lorsqu'une information subit
un biais cognitif alors elle est biaisée
c'est à dire qu'elle détournée, quelle est
malaxée, qu'elle perd son sens initial
et du coup
notre raisonnement est erroné.
C'est le biais d'optimisme, qui par exemple
dans le cadre d'une épidémie
fait qu'on se sent moins
à risque que les autres
et donc qu'on va prendre un peu moins
ses précautions que les autres.
Et pourtant dans le même temps,
on va être capable d'être très critique
envers d'autres personnes,
qui ne prennent pas les précautions
qu'il faudrait, comme nous.
C'est le cas par exemple de
l'utilisation du préservatif
qui oblige à des campagnes
de sensibilisation régulières.
Les magiciens qui ont pour métier
de tromper notre cerveau
utilisent les biais cognitifs pour nous
illusionner avec notre consentement.
Et ça, c'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant.
Evidemment, c'est les magiciens
qui utilisent le mieux les biais cognitifs
des fois sans le savoir, parce qu'ils
ont besoin de tromper le cerveau
et donc par la force des choses
et par l'expérience ils ont compris des trucs.
Je vais faire un tour hyper classique.
Il y a un docteur en psychologie,
Albert Moukheiber.
il a sorti un livre, qui s'appelle
votre cerveau vous joue des tours.
Il a référencé comme ça,
des tours très classiques
qui fonctionnent et qui sont
des bonnes bases de connaissances
pour mieux les comprendre.
Le tour est hyper simple,
il y a quelques cartes et je te demande
d'en retenir une et une seule.
Et tu me dis quand tu en as une en tête.
- Ouais.
- tu as fait ton choix ? .
- Okay.
Regarde moi...
un plaisir.
Okay, je vais en enlever une,  je fais un choix
mais je pense que c'est elle.
Je la pose sous le paquet,
comme ça je peux pas la perdre
je pense que c'est pas cette carte,
que ta carte en tout cas,
c'est celle que j'ai enlevée.
Est-ce que tu vois toujours ta carte ?
- Non
- Non ?
- Non.
Donc c'est bon, je l'ai enlevée.
C'est un tour réussi,
c'est un tour validé.
- Okay.
-  Validé par les biais cognitifs
J'ai pas du tout enlevé ta carte,
enfin pas vraiment,
j'ai bien enlevé une carte.
Mais c'est pas forcément la tienne.
En fait j'ai enlevé toutes les cartes,
que tu as vues au départ,
c'est pas du tout le même
set de cartes maintenant,
que le set que tu as eu au début.
Et c'était laquelle ta carte, d'ailleurs ?
- C'était celle-là.
- La dame de trèfle, qui a été remplacée
simplement par la dame de pic.
Et en fait tu as vécu ce qu'on appelle,
un biais de sélection
et un biais de confirmation.
C'est à dire que tu n'as cherché
que ce qui correspondait à ton choix
et donc ça a confirmé pour toi, que j'avais
réussi,  puisque ton choix n'était pas là.
et ça c'est un biais cognitif
hyper classique,
qui est la source des discriminations
et du racisme par exemple.
Parce qu'on va chercher toujours les infos
qui correspondent à ce qu'on croit nous.
Et on le voit avec ce tour de magie.
Est-ce que tu remets ta vie
en question, Simon ?
- Ouais, ça a commencé.
Mon choix, mon parcours, mes erreurs...
Ouais, bien joué.
Bravo.
Le biais de sélection et de confirmation
étaient utilisés dans le premier tour
car nous cherchions la carte
que nous avions choisi.
Pour confirmer son absence
et c'est ce raisonnement qui nous a donné
l'illusion que le tour avait fonctionné.
Ce biais est dangereux
quand il s'agit de nos opinions,
car on va vouloir spontanément
tendance à aller chercher
de l'information qui conforte
nos opinions de base.
Le biais de sélection
et de confirmation
est malheureusement souvent à l'origine
des discriminations, du racisme, etc.
Avant de passer à la suite,
je vous rappelle que cette vidéo
est sponsorisée par...
- Bah par toi, c'est tout le temps toi.
Il n'y a pas de sponsors
pour "Matière grise".
- Toujours par moi même.
- Pourquoi on est en colère déjà ?
- Parce qu'on vient de payer les impôts.
- On a qu'à écrire un livre.
- On pourrait faire un tour de table
avec tout le monde et on trouve le sujet.
- Et il est où bonheur ? On peut pas le faire si
y'a bonheur, il n'est jamais celui-là.
- C'est là dessus qu'on devrait
écrire un livre,
je suis sûr que Fabien a plein de trucs
à dire sur le bonheur
et puis l'échec qui se pointe
toujours aussi.
- Pas con.
Le bonheur est caché dans
un coin de votre cerveau,
c'est mon nouveau livre
qui est sorti le 24 septembre,
dans toutes les librairies, dans les Fnac,
dans les Cultura, sur internet.
Et ça traite principalement du bonheur.
Il n'y a pas trop de surprise.
Mais surtout de l'échec, de la flexibilité
mentale, de la réussite,
et de toute ma vie que
j'ai dû mettre un petit peu à nu
pour vous dire qu'on pouvait changer son
rapport à l'échec et son rapport au bonheur.
Voici une étude très étonnante qui
a eu lieu en 2006, en Allemagne.
On a demandé à des juges de faire
un exercice très simple.
De lire le compte rendu d'un vol
à l'étalage hyper classique.
Un peu plus tard, on a demandé
à ces mêmes juges de lancer deux dés.
Mais les dés étaient
complètement pipés
et le résultat obtenu
était forcément 3...
ou 9.
Toujours un peu plus tard,
on a demandé à ces mêmes juges
de prononcer une sentence
pour le vol à l'étalage.
On leur disait, combien de mois
de prison pour le voleur ?
Les juges qui ont obtenu neuf au dé,
ont donné en moyenne huit mois
de prison, comme sentence.
Les juges qui ont obtenu 3 au dé,
ont donné, en moyenne cinq mois
de sentence pour le voleur.
Evidemment, ça c'est à cause d'un biais
et c'est le biais d' ancrage.
Le biais d'un ancrage est tellement
fort, qu'il fonctionne sur des juges
qui ont pourtant 15 ans d'expérience
et dont l'image du résultat des dés,
n'a pourtant rien à voir avec le vol à l'étalage.
T'as compris le concept, c'est quand
tu as une idée ou un raisonnement,
en fait ça t'appartient pas vraiment.
C'est tout ce que tu as vécu dans ta vie
qui fait que ça prend des raccourcis
pour plein de raisons différentes,
parce qu'il faut décider vite, il faut agir vite.
Et ça ça vient de quand on était
à la préhistoire,
de se dire, j'ai mangé
un champignon rouge.
J'étais malade.
Du coup tous les champignons rouges,
je vais faire gaffe.
On fait des raccourcis
de cerveau, tu vois.
J'ai envie d'essayer un truc avec toi,
c'est un truc que j'ai vu à la télévision,
Le soir, tard.
Je me suis dit, tiens si je vois Simon,
on fait ça ensemble.
Il faudrait que tu fasses un choix
dans ta tête.
Que tu penses à un édifice.
N'importe quel édifice en fait.
En France.
Connu, assez connu en tout cas,
pour que je le connaisse
et d'une construction
relativement récente.
Pas des pyramides d'Egypte
par exemple.
- Qui ne sont pas du tout en France
en plus, pour le coup.
- Du coup, tu choisis un édifice,
construction relativement récente,
quelque part en France.
Tu me dis pas lequel évidemment.
- Okay, récente ça veut dire
pas très lointaine dans le temps ?
- On peut s'offrir deux cents ans.
- Okay.
- Ou 300 ans, tu vois...
- Mais ça peut être un immeuble connu...
- Oui voilà, exactement.
- Un portail connu par exemple.
Donc mon choix de monument est...
fait.
Okay, change.
Non, je rigole.
C'est juste pour le plaisir
de te voir galérer.
J'ai senti qu'il y avait pas
eu un grand choix.
- Bah oui, okay.
- Ce monument, je vais dire
à peu près ce que je perçois
et j'expliquerai après
comment je fais.
- Attends, mais parce que je crois
que j'ai changé
entre le moment où j'ai choisi
et où tu m'as dit change.
- Eh bien change alors.
- J'ai changé.
- Okay.
Tu veux rechanger pour le premier ?
- Je m'arrête ici, c'est bon.
Et du coup ce que je pensais
c'est plus, bon alors.
c'est ça qui est très
sensible envers toi.
- Okay.
- Non, non mais on garde le deuxième.
- Le deuxième ?
- Le deuxième.
Comme ça si ça marche pas,
j'ai une bonne excuse.
- Okay, okay, le deuxième.
- Comme ça, c'est intéressant pour moi.
Assez spontanément, j'ai un truc d'eau
autour ou à côté.
Est-ce que ça parle ?
J'ai une source d'eau pas loin.
- Je suis pas sûr qu'elle...
- Tu connais peut-être pas
assez le lieu, okay.
j'ai quelque chose de
très clair d'ailleurs,
il y a beaucoup de clarté, d'espace.
Dans la structure comme un
espèce de U inversé.
Pas l'Arc de triomphe non plus
mais on est quand même sur tu vois,
quelque chose d'arrondi à l'envers.
J'ai un arrondi très présent,
beaucoup d'activités,
beaucoup, de mouvements autour.
J'ai les couleurs bleues et rouges.
Peut-être au-dessus ?
Est ce que ça te parle ça
ou c'est moi dans ma tête ?
- C'est toute la complexité du truc.
C'est que ça me parle sur
un des deux que j'ai choisi.
- Okay.
Est-ce que tout match plus
sur l'un des deux ?
- Ouais.
- Ah okay, donc je suis sur
le premier c'est ça ?
- Ouais.
- Okay, d'accord et c'est quoi
le premier du coup ?
- C'est Beaubourg.
- Et c'est Beaubourg.
Et donc on a tout.
On a des arrondis, le rouge, le bleu
les gens de passage, on a tout.
Donc je t'ai décris Beaubourg.
Ce qui est déjà pas si mal du coup.
- Ce qui est déjà un respect.
- Okay, maintenant on peut parler de ça.
- Carrément.
En fait ça, c'est Patrick Froment,
qui est un autre mentaliste
qui a écrit un livre et que je connais bien
et il a référencé un truc à la télévision
qui est juste dingue.
C'est un voyant qui devine
des monuments dans une enveloppe.
A un moment donné, ils ont fait ce test
pour voir la fiabilité de sa voyance.
Ce que je t'ai dit c'est
exactement ce qu'il a dit.
Ni plus, ni moins.
Et en fait Patrick Froment,
en faisant un peu de recherche,
il s'est aperçu que pour
tous les monuments
relativement récents, en France,
connus d'un peu tout le monde.
La plupart de ces éléments-là matchent.
Et on s'est dit, mais comment
ça se fait que ça fonctionne du coup ?
Parce que il y a l'effet Forer,
autrement appelé l'effet barnum,
qui fait que des généralités
ou des choses vagues,
tu vas te les approprier pour
que ça colle à quelque chose.
- Okay.
- Moi je sais pas de quoi je t'ai parlé.
Je t'ai répété ce que disait le voyant en fait.
Mais si tu avais choisi la tour TF1,
- Oui.
- En fait il y a de la clarté,
il y a l'activité autour,
il y a de l'eau à côté
avec la Seine
il y a le bleu et rouge en haut,
et tout fonctionne.
Il y a le U inversé,
tu le colles où tu veux.
Mais si tu prends la tour Eiffel,
le U inversé, on le voit aussi dans le bas
il y a de l'activité,
des gens autour, l'eau autour.
Le bleu et rouge,
du bleu, blanc, rouge de l'Etat Français.
- Ah oui, oui d'accord, okay.
- Et l'effet Barnum, l'effet Forer
il est un peu ouf.
C'est ce qui fait que les horoscopes
fonctionnent par exemple.
On peut croire en l'astrologie,
ça c'est pas le problème.
Mais en tout cas,
qu'on y croit ou pas,
on va toujours ramener à ce qu'on
connaît de nous-mêmes pour se dire,
"c'est quand même
incroyable ça
parce qu'il a dit exactement ce que
j'avais dans la tête".
Et en poussant un petit peu
avec des lieux communs
c'est un truc qu'on utilise beaucoup
en mentalisme, en cold reading.
On peut donner le sentiment à la personne
d'avoir lu sa pensée alors qu'on n'a rien lu.
On peut lui faire même donner la réponse
sans qu'elle s'en rende compte,
pour la réutiliser 15 minutes plus tard.
Et dire, "du coup je pense
que tu penses ça "
et la personne fait "wow".
- En ratissant large.
- Oui.
- En coupant des éléments
vagues mais évocateurs,
on peut trouver n'importe quoi.
- C'est vrai.
- Moi, je peux faire une séance
de voyance comme ça.
Moi je perçois juste une douleur
à un moment,
mais c'était vraiment
il y a des années
et ça a été une trahison pour toi.
Des fois encore, tu y repenses
même parfois,
- Ouais, ouais.
- Et ça construit un peu
différemment parce que tu dis
"okay maintenant je vais être
un peu plus dur",
mais au fond de toi tu sais que
ça n'a pas complètement guérie.
Tu vois ça fait partie de
ta vie et on peut...
- Ouais.
- Aller très loin.
Quand on prétend savoir
des choses sur vous,
Demandez toujours
des détails de ça.
Demandez toujours un peu plus de
confirmation, de choses comme ça.
Ne donnez pas la réponse avant l'autre,
parce que sachez que votre cerveau
a besoin de donner de
la cohérence et du sens à tout.
Il va toujours en chercher.
Il voit un numéro de train,
s'il y a une date de naissance dedans,
il va se dire : "mais c'est fou
quand même
parce que ça c'est quand même
le train qui est important
et j'ai vu ma date de
naissance dedans
C'est quand même un signe... ".
Non, c'est un train.
Là, il n'y a vraiment rien voir.
Voici un autre genre de biais,
l'effet barnum ou encore l'effet forer.
Ce biais force notre cerveau à accepter
quelque chose de vague, de général
comme étant quelque chose
de personnel à nous.
Tout à l'heure, votre cerveau a
cherché à donner du sens
entre ce que nous disions
et ce que vous pensiez,
pour que tout soit cohérent.
Cet effet de validation subjectif
est d'ailleurs ce qui est reproché
aux médiums et aux voyants.
Le meilleur moyen d'étudier un biais cognitif
est encore de le démontrer sur un groupe.
Plusieurs études ont été réalisées
sur le sujet
et des documentaires ont même
été fait en caméra cachée
c'est exactement ce qui va
se passer maintenant.
Des abonnés ont été invités
à participer à ce tournage.
Tous ont reçu un mail
avec des consignes.
Tous.
Sauf un.
Et c'est ce que vous allez
découvrir, maintenant.
On va faire ensemble des
tests de questions, réponses.
il n'y a pas de piège, il n'y a pas de trucs
à gagner ou de trucs à perdre.
C'est les statistiques des réponses
et des groupes de réponses
qui vont m'intéresser par la suite.
Donc si vous savez pas,
vous tentez une réponse,
essayez de répondre
quelque chose.
Parce qu'en fait, vous n'avez
pas trop le choix.
Puisque pour me répondre
vous allez devoir lever la main, okay ?
A chaque réponse, si je dirai :
"Est-ce que c'est un ou deux,
si c'est deux, levez la main".
Je considère que si la main
est pas levée, c'est un.
Est-ce que ça c'est clair ?
si oui, levez la main.
C'est parfait.
-Au cas où, au cas où.
- J'ai l'impression de t'engueuler.
Quand j'ai vu ton attitude,
- Moi je sais que je la ramène pas.
- Ouais, c'est vrai.
En gros, c'est les questions que j'ai pris
en m'inspirant du film "conition"
qui est sorti, il y a un mois.
Tout le monde l'a vu ici ?
Levez la main ce qu'ils ont vu.
Okay, tout le monde l'a vu.
Ah, tu l'as pas vu.
Deux personnes l'ont pas vu.
La première question va voir si vous avez vu
le dernier épisode de matière grise.
C'est ce qui me prouve votre fidélité
envers mon travail.
Pourquoi vous détournez le regard ?
T'étais très intéressé par
cette tâche là sur la table.
- Non, j'étais plus là dessus,
je me disais :
"c'est incroyable ce nœud qui
reflète avec le soleil".
- Quelle est la ville la plus au sud
entre New-York et Rome ?
Levez la main pour New-York.
Si je lâche 1 kilo de plomb
ou 1 kilo de bois en même temps,
lequel arrive au sol en premier ?
Levez la main pour le bois.
Est-ce que quelqu'un a des commentaires
à faire sur ma question ?
- C'est les deux, parce que ce soit en bois
ou en plume, ils ont la même masse.
- Exactement, et c'était très intéressant
pour moi d'avoir cette réaction là,
de voir les yeux qui faisaient...
"En fait, il a dit si je lève pas,
c'est que je réponds quand même
et là du coup c'est vraiment pas cool".
Okay, c'était vraiment
pour donner de la matière
que je commenterai plus tard
dans la vidéo.
Toi tu aurais dit quoi ?
- Moi non, j'aurais dit exactement
comme la mademoiselle.
- Je voyais, tu sais, les mouvements
de lèvre.
- Bah ouais, c'est la politesse,
c'est de l'éducation.
- C'est assez respectueux.
- Excusez moi d'être poli.
- Pardon.
- D'être un mec bien.
Combien de tableau a vendu Van Gogh,
de son vivant ?
Un ou Onze ?
Levez la main pour un.
ça c'est intéressant,
j'ai regardé si le...
A l'école, on avait pas
des trucs comme ça ?
on avait pas demis trucs de...
- ça me colle une pression incroyable
ce truc, je vois pas pourquoi.
Du coup c'est Simon qui vous
donne la réponse c'était...
ça commence par un 1.
- Et ça finit par un 1, super.
Je dirais un.
- Un ?
- Ouais.
- Ouais c'est ça, c'est un.
Il a vendu qu'un seul tableau de son vivant
tout le reste, ça a été post mortem.
Est-ce que mon vrai prénom
est Fabien Olicard,
ou est-ce que j'ai pris
un pseudo pour la scène ?
Qui peut être que sur le prénom
ou que sur le nom de famille évidemment.
Levez la main, si vous pensez
que j'ai pris un pseudo ?
Pseudo pour tout le monde.
On passe à la question suivante,
c'est tout à fait correct.
Si je mélange du jaune et du bleu.
Jaune et bleu.
Est-ce que j'obtiens
du verre ou du orange ?
Levez la main pour orange.
Quel est l'origine du mot parmentier ?
Est-ce que c'est le nom de son inventeur ?
Ou le fait qu'on mettait avant
du jambon de parme ?
Levez la main pour...
Euh non.
Levez la main pour, inventeur.
Combien de face a un cube ?
Quatre ou six ?
Levez la main pour quatre.
Okay, on est bon pour tout ?
Très bien.
Donc qu'est ce qu'on vient
de faire exactement ?
On vient de faire ce qu'on appelle
un test de conformité.
Qui a marché parfois et
qui parfois n'a pas fonctionné.
Le test de conformité
c'est à dire que,
en réalité certains d'entre vous,
avez les réponses en avance.
Quand je dis certains
c'est tout le monde, sauf toi.
Tu n'as pas levé la main sur
le film "conition", tout à l'heure ?
- Oui.
Tu l'as pas vu ?
- Non.
- Okay, parce qu'il n'existe pas.
- Ah bah voilà.
Mais eux étaient au courant
et je voulais voir un petit peu
si t'allais lever la main ou pas.
Merci Simon d'avoir levé la main.
Fabien Olicard,
c'est mon vrai nom.
Je sais que ça se sait ou
que ça se pressent.
Mais je voulais voir un petit peu,
si quand tout le monde
commençaient à lever la main
s'il n'y a pas de doute,
est-ce que tout le monde lèvera bien
la main là dessus.
Sur le pseudo tout le monde s'est dit :
"Oui, elle est simple celle-là".
Est-ce que tu connaissais
sincèrement la réponse sur :
Si je mélange du jaune et du bleu,
j'obtiens du verre ou du orange ?
La réponse c'est du vert,
c'est un truc qui est assez connu.
Je me suis demandé si tu connaissais
la vraie réponse ou pas ?
- Pas du tout.
- Pas du tout ?
- Aucune idée.
- Donc comme t'as eu aucune idée,
tu t'es dit, je me plie
au groupe à ce moment là ?
- Complètement.
- C'est ça qui s'est passé ?
- Ouais.
- Okay, ça c'est intéressant de se dire
dans le biais de conformité,
qu'on appelle aussi ça
le mouton de panurge en fait.
On suit le groupe, si on sait pas.
Tu vois plutôt que d'être
à l'inverse du groupe,
Parce que ton hasard ça aurait pu
être de te dire aussi,
je lève pas la main parce que je sais pas
et c'est la réponse inverse, peu importe.
C'est qu'on va avoir tendance
à suivre le groupe, okay.
Parmentier, tu savais pas que
ça venait de son inventeur ?
- Pas du tout.
- Eh bien à partir de maintenant
ce sera le jambon de parme pour toi.
Mais c'est leur gré dans parme
et donc pareil tu as suivi le groupe
de la même manière dans cette étape là,
tu t'es dit s'ils levaint la main
c'est qu'ils savent ?
- Un peu ouais.
- Ouais, okay.
Et alors, maintenant, je suis très curieux
de savoir ce qui s'est passé,
pourquoi t'as pas levé
la main sur le cube ?
- Je l'ai visualisé.
- Ouais, et tu t'es dit, il y a six faces.
- Un, deux, trois, quatre et un, deux.
Et le fait que tout le monde lève la main,
ça t'a perturbé une seconde ou pas ?
- Non.
- Non ?
- Non, je l'avais dans la tête.
Okay, donc tu étais sûr de ta donnée ?
- Oui.
- Okay, c'est hyper intéressant parce que
dans des expériences plus longues
qui ont été faites mais qui prennent
une heure et demie
et donc j'allais pas
la reproduire aujourd'hui.
Quand on fait des tests, comme ça
sur toutes les personnes
et donc il y a une ou deux personnes,
comme ça qui est dans le test
qui subissent ce que tu viens de subir.
Il y a une heure de questions normales
et après au fur à mesure
il y a des fausses réponses qui arrivent,
qui sont parsemées et clairsemées.
C'est assez passionnant,
parce que eux,
ils viennent en plus pour
quelque chose à gagner.
Un job, quelque chose, tu vois.
Donc il y a un vrai enjeu.
et le test du cube a été fait,
qui est est un test assez basique,
personne ne se trompe à ça.
Et tu vois les personnes se mettent
à lever la main sur quatre,
de manière contre nature et donc je voulais
voir si ça allait le faire aussi rapidement.
J'en doutais un peu
mais de savoir que là,
ça t'as même pas traversé l'esprit.
Je trouve ça trop cool.
Merci beaucoup en tout cas
que vous vous êtes prêté au jeu
c'était la raison principale
de votre venue ici
parce que faire le test de conformité
que sur une personne
c'était moins marrant, voilà.
Merci à vous !
Que s'est-il passé ?
Nous avons pu assister
au biais de conformité,
autrement appelé
le syndrome de panurge,
par rapport aux moutons
qui suivent le groupe.
Pourtant, il faut que vous sachiez
que le groupe
a répondu faux de manière
volontaire par rapport aux mails
et aux consignes qu'on leur
avait données avant.
Une seule personne parmi eux
n'avait pas reçu le mail et les consignes.
La vraie question c'est :
Est-ce que cette personne a répondu faux,
parce qu'elle n'avait pas la réponse ?
Ou parce qu'elle a voulu
se conformer au groupe ?
Voici une étude de 2013,
de l'université de Brighton
qui fait suite aux travaux du psychologue
Solomon Asch dans les années 50.
Il semblerait que ce soit l'insula,
situé au niveau du cortex cérébral
qui s'activerait lorsqu'elle sent qu'on va se
faire rejeter du groupe auquel on appartient.
L'insula collecte des
informations émotionnelles
et sous la pression
d'un potentiel rejet,
peut lâcher son opinion de base,
pour se conformer au groupe.
Une autre étude de 2012
se référant à Condorcet,
a étudié le système de
pensée des votants.
1 000 personnes devant voter
pour un candidat ont été réunies.
Ils avaient tous un vote qui était
clair et défini dans leur tête.
Juste avant qu'ils n'aillent voter,
on leur a fait voir un sondage
et ce sondage montrait volontairement,
le candidat opposé au leur,
largement en tête.
Qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé ?
25% des électeurs ont changé
leur vote à la dernière seconde,
en faveur du vote mis en avant
dans les sondages.
Une personne sur quatre.
Avec un simple sondage.
Cela démontre qu'il faut arrêter
de publier des sondages permanents,
qu'ils soient réels ou trafiqués.
Ce n'est même pas la question
qu'on se pose.
Méfiez-vous du biais de conformité,
soyez toujours libres de vos opinions
et réfléchissez toujours,
Si vous avez un raisonnement
par rapport à vos pensées
ou par rapport au groupe.
[Musique]
Il y aurait plus de 250
biais cognitifs différents.
Ils sont intentionnels,
ou mnésiques
ou de jugement,
ou de raisonnement
ou simplement liés
à votre personnalité,
elle même imprégnée de vos
caractéristiques socioculturelles.
Passons maintenant à
quelques questions.
Vous l'avez peut-être compris,
on va passer au "c'est à vous",
donc le "C'est à vous",
je vais vous poser des questions
et vous allez y répondre.
Dans les commentaires,
si vous êtes honnêtes.
Si vous n'êtes pas honnêtes dans
les commentaires,
dans dix secondes, une fois que
vous avez la réponse.
Et quoi qu'il arrive, Simon
va le vivre en même temps que vous.
- Aller.
- Comme c'est une vidéo
sur les biais cognitifs
et que vous n'êtes pas idiots.
C'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle.
- Ah bah clairement.
- C'est un jugement personnel.
- Oui, oui.
- Tout me tend à le confirmer.
- J'espère bien.
- Ne me déçois pas.
Comme vous n'êtes pas idiots
vous savez que c'est des questions
qui vont être piégées
et piégeantes parfois.
Pas toujours, mais parfois.
Donc je vous laisse un laps de temps
limité pour me pour formuler,
me proposer une réponse.
- Très bien.
- Question numéro une...
je suis le frère de ces deux médecins.
Pourtant ces deux médecins
ne sont pas mes frères.
Pourquoi ?
- Eh bien, je ne sais pas.
- C'est vrai ?
- Attends.
- Mais en même temps les
10 secondes sont bien cramées.
- Non il y a au moins quatre secondes,
- C'est vrai ?
- Ouais, il m'en reste un peu.
-  J'ai une mauvaise perception du temps
quand je suis sur une table.
- Attends, quoi, je suis le frère
de ces deux médecins ?
- Ouais bah ça c'est vrai.
- Et pourtant...
- Ces deux médecins ne
sont pas mes frères.
- Je sais pas ça va m'énerver, non ?
- Ouais.
- Parce que c'est genre simple et tout ?
- Oui.
- Vas-y.
- Bah c'est mes sœurs en fait.
- Ouais c'est de l'humiliation
publique quoi.
- Mais moi, je t'avais proposé qu'on dise
une question sur deux.
- Ah, oui d'accord, oui,
d'accord, d'accord
- Mais en fait c'est un biais.
C'est un biais genré,
où maintenant on se dit toujours
un médecin, c'est un homme.
Et toi en plus, le pire,
c'est que par ton métier
tu travailles à l'imaginaire,
donc tu as tout de suite eu des images
de médecins masculins dans ta tête
et va basculer, pour avoir l'inverse
c'est quasi impossible.
- C'est ça, tu m'a trouvée
une super excuse,
je n'aurais pas trouvé mieux
comme excuse.
On la coupera celle-ci.
- Un homme peut-il épouser
la sœur de sa veuve ?
- Waouh quoi ?
- si elle n'est pas médecin.
- Un homme, peut-il épouser
la sœur de sa veuve ?
- Ou l'épousseter aussi.
Il peut épousseter qui il veut.
- Epouser la sœur de
sa veuve de quoi ?
Mais de quoi ?
Déjà la question est bizarre.
- Pourquoi ?
- Ben parce que déjà tu dis
pourquoi faire ça ?
- Et pourquoi pas ?
- Et la veuve de qui ?
- L'amour...
- Ah !
Un homme peut-il épouser
la sœur de sa veuve, donc...
Ben non parce qu'il est mort.
- Oui !
- Aller !
- Bravo !
- Tu pourras, genre couper
tout le temps où je réfléchis,
pour vraiment, ce soit ultra cut ?
- Ouais, complètement.
- Du coup tu vas pas mettre
ce passage là.
- Celui-là, il faut le couper et tout
ce que je dis là, il faut couper.
Là, on reprend maintenant.
- Question 3 !
Avant la découverte de l'Everest,
quel était le sommet le plus
haut de la terre ?
- Bah l'Everest.
- Joli.
Est-ce qu'on pourra
rallonger ce passage,
et mettre une réflexion de sa part ?
Non mais c'est la passion de
mon fils qui a 9 ans
et qui a un livre comme ça,
avec une tête d'Einstein dessus,
qui me rend fou et avec
des énigmes et il fait ça.
- Ah oui.
- avec les pièges et tout.
Là, j'étais bien sur les
deux quand même.
- C'était assez inspirant.
Je peux utiliser le mot inspiration,
quand tu réponds ?
- Tu pourrais même l'inscrire.
- Okay.
Il est même écrit là, en gras.
- Clignote.
Et là, il y a des flammes.
- C'est fou. Le travail du monteur
est incroyable.
- Là, il y a un réacteur qui part,
c'est comme une fusée dans le ciel.
- C'est vrai ?
- Avec des paillettes.
- Et là, c'est toi qui est dans
le ciel maintenant.
- Ah sérieux ?
- C'est fou.
Tu as décollé.
Question 4, de retour dans le studio.
- Oui.
- Un train... alors là c'est chaud.
Un train part de Paris vers Marseille
- Ouais.
- Et roule à 100 km/h.
Il est tranquille.
- Oui, oui.
- Petite vitesse.
Et au même instant un autre train
part de Marseille pour aller vers Paris,
donc vraiment le trajet inverse.
Mais lui roule à 200 km/h.
Au moment où ils vont se croiser...
- Aller
- Quel sera le train le plus
proche de Paris ?
Tu veux que je te répète
toutes les données maintenant ?
- Non.
Okay, ils sont pas en grève déjà.
- D'accord, non mais très bien.
Donc moi, je roule une heure, je fais ça.
Moi, je roule une heure, je fais ça.
Le plus proche de Paris c'est celui
qui part de paris non ?
- Paris-Marseille, 100 km/h,
Marseille-Paris, 200 km/h.
- En un heure, tu fais 200 km.
Mais...
Ah, quand ils se croisent !
- Oui, au moment où
ils vont se rencontrer.
Moi j'ai fait, ils s'arrêtent
au bout d'une heure,
ce qui n'a aucun intérêt, dans le trajet
- Non, non.
Non, et puis en plus ça fait prendre
du retard, c'est hyper relou.
Quand tu préviens ta mère qui
devait devenir te chercher,
elle voulait pas prendre de ticket
elle a attendu devant.
Tu connais ça ?
C'est relou, c'est relou.
- Okay.
Oui donc au moment
où ils se croisent,
oui de toute façon,
on m'a dit la réponse.
Donc, c'est donc le train
qui part de Marseille.
- Et c'est pas ça n'est pas plus.
Ah bon ?
Les deux sont au même endroit ?
- Oui, ils se croisent.
Lequel est le plus proche de Paris ?
- Eh bien super, voilà.
Voilà, vous êtes super quoi.
Moi je suis...
- Elle est horrible cette question ?
- Ouais.
- Un biais de complexité,
ni plus ni moins.
C'est comme tu as pleins
de données,
tu as l'impression qu'il faut
calculer des trucs
et tu oublies la donnée de base,
qui est, s'ils se croisent,
ils sont au même endroit.
Donc s'ils sont au même endroit,
ils sont à la même distance,
- Ah mais oui !
- que de Paris et de Marseille.
Ils sont au même endroit.
Si jamais tu veux le noter...
- Par contre t'étais pas aussi reculé,
t'étais un peu plus comme ça,
t'étais moins détendu.
- "Au même endroit".
Alors là, le dernier,
ton enfant il a quel âge ?
- 9 ans.
- Un enfant plus jeune que ton fils,
il aurait sûrement la bonne réponse
à la prochaine question.
En tout cas plus facilement
qu'un adulte.
- Okay.
Il y a trois personnes qui
sont dans le désert.
- Donc déjà, oui...
- Depuis trop longtemps...
- Oui.
- Les yeux bandés.
Donc tu as 3 personnes qui
sont dans le désert,
elles sont à la file indienne.
Il n'y a aucun piège dans
ce que je vais te dire.
C'est à dire que tu as
vraiment un,
l'autre qui est derrière lui
dans le même sens,
dans le même sens.
- Ouais, ouais.
- Ils mesurent la même taille,
il n'y a pas de piège comme ça.
Le premier dit: "Devant moi,
je vois que le désert".
Le deuxième dit: "devant moi,
je vois la tête d'un mec,
qui est devant moi."
Et le troisième dit: "Devant moi,
je vois que le désert."
Comment c'est possible ?
- Bah ils marchent à reculons ?
- Non ils sont vraiment,
il n'y a pas de piège,
Ils sont vraiment en file
indienne, normal.
- Ils mesurent 7 mètres 50 ?
- Oui mais tous alors,
ils font tous la même taille.
- Ah oui c'est vrai.
Il ne perçoit pas son...
Il est constitué de telle manière,
qu'il ne voit pas les humains ?
- Mais non.
- c'est possible.
- C'est possible, mais pas là.
- Le premier ne voit que le désert...
- Le deuxième...
- Mais là on parle de gens
qui sont dans l'ordre ?
- Ouais.
- T'es pas en train de me faire
un espèce de truc,
je t'envoie là pour que
tu penses ça...
- Je te fais les bonhommes,
je te fais les bonhommes.
- Okay.
- Jean-Jacques il regarde par là,
il dit : "Moi je vois que le désert".
- Okay, bon Jean-Jacques
est honnête.
- Là, c'est jean-mi,
il refaisait son lacet,
Mais quand il est à
la même hauteur, il dit :
"devant moi je vois un mec
qui ressemble à un marteau de juge"
- Okay, okay.
ça complique beaucoup.
Que ce soit des juges, des yeux...
- C'est pas faux.
Le deuxième dit :"Moi je suis médecin de
ces deux frères et ça n'a plus de sens.
Il est bien derrière, on voit bien
qu'il regarde bien la bonne direction.
Lui on a pas de problème.
Et il dit: "devant moi,
je vois que le désert".
Comment c'est possible ?
- Donc là, le dernier ne voit
que le désert ?
Il dit je ne vois que le désert.
Comment c'est possible ?
- Il ment ?
- Qui a dit qu'il mentait ?
C'est exactement ça.
Il ment.
Tout simplement.
Et maintenant je vous laisse
avec vous-même,
réfléchir pourquoi,
on se dit : On va pas remettre en cause
l'honnêteté de ces personnes
parce que c'est une énigme, parce que
c'est Fabien, parce que ceci, cela,
parce que mon cerveau
est très intelligent,
il va trouver quelque chose
d'hyper rationnel
plutôt que cette logique de base.
Bah il ment.
Et quand tu fais ce test là
sur des enfants.
Plus ils sont jeunes, plus ils disent :
"c'est pas vrai, qu'est-ce qu'il dit".
C'est complètement faux.
Et ils ont raison, c'est pas vrai.
- Mais ça, c'est parce que
c'est ma conception du,
je suis trop pur en fait, je pense.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait appeler cette vidéo
test de pureté avec Simon Astier ?
Moi je pense que je fais
des vues avec ça.
- Ah ouais, je pense que là
si tu passes le test
des yeux, du cerveau
et du marteau.
- Ouais.
- ça veut dire que tu as le corps pur.
En 2016, Buster Benson
a déterminé les raisons
pour laquelle nous utilisons
des biais cognitif, en permanence.
Parce que c'est pas un hasard
que notre cerveau utilise ces raccourcis
ou ces manières de
retraiter l'information.
Les raisons sont les suivantes :
La première, le cerveau reçoit beaucoup
trop d'informations d'un coup.
La deuxième, le cerveau veut donner
du sens aux informations qu'il reçoit.
La troisième, c'est que le cerveau
doit agir ou décider très rapidement.
Et enfin la quatrième, c'est que le cerveau
doit retenir des informations
issues d'une expérience, pour
potentiellement s'en servir plus tard.
Il en fait donc une conclusion générale.
Mais il est loin le temps où
on devait se méfier d'un aliment
parce qu'il ressemblait,
de près ou de loin,
à un autre aliment qui nous avait
rendu malade précédemment.
Il faut donc se méfier
de ces biais,
en analysant en permanence
les pensées qu'on a dans sa tête
et pourquoi elles viennent.
Et si on jette un bon regard sur le flot
de pensées qu'on a dans le cerveau.
On pourra alors trier
l'information de base,
la vraie pensée,
bien avant qu'elle ne soit corrompue
par les biais cognitifs.
Merci à tous les participants,
merci à toute l'équipe.
Merci à Fanny à la production,
à Loïc à la réalisation.
Et un grand merci à Simon Astier
qui a sauvé ce tournage en remplaçant
un invité à la dernière minute.
C'était super chouette de sa part.
D'ailleurs, vous pouvez aller le voir
jouer au théâtre Michel,
à partir du 3 Décembre où
il va interpréter le discours.
Le lien est dans la description.
Vous pouvez liker cette vidéo,
la partager, vous abonner,
c'est gratuit.
Evidemment pour ne pas rater
les prochains épisodes.
Et les précédents épisodes de
matière grise sont dans la description.
Alors pouvons nous améliorer
notre dépendance aux biais ?
Sommes-nous vraiment maîtres
de nos raisonnements ?
Pouvons-nous changer
notre système de pensée ?
Nous aurons la réponse
à tout cela et bien plus,
dans les prochains épisodes
de matière grise.
A très bientôt,
ciao !